- Hi, everyone, good afternoon.
I'm Priya Natarajan,
I'm the current director
of the Franke Program in
Science and the Humanities.
I'm a astrophysicist.
I am just really delighted you're here.
This is to really give you a warm welcome
to our first convening this fall
as we open up our programming
for this academic year in person,
and I'm really grateful
that you all are here.
We have a very exciting
event for this evening,
a wonderful, thought-provoking film
by a very young talented filmmaker,
and he happens to be a Yale alum as well.
More about that in just a minute.
First, I would like to start
with thanking our benefactors,
Mr. and Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
for their generosity in supporting us
in multiple other activities at Yale.
As you all know, we lost
Mr. Franke this summer,
and so there will be a memorial service
to honor his legacy, his contributions,
and his unflagging support
for many cross-disciplinary
activities at Yale.
As a flagship interdisciplinary
program at Yale
that bridges the so-called
sort of, you know,
two cultures that C.P. Snow
came up with in the 1950s,
the sciences and the humanities,
here, we have been catalyzing
intellectual collaborations
across disciplinary boundaries and silos,
and as every year, we are now delighted
to welcome many of our
young undergraduate,
graduate, and post-doctoral Franke Fellows
whose work actually
crosses many disciplines.
And before we move on to the event,
I'm required to give you this notice.
This event is being
recorded and photographed
for educational, archival,
and promotional purposes,
including use in print and on the internet
and other forms of media.
By attending this event today,
you agree to the possibility
of your voice or likeness
captured by these means
and used for such purposes
without compensation to you
and hereby waive any related
right of privacy or publicity.
So moving on to today's program,
we are screening the film "Unconformity"
by the filmmaker Jonathan DiMaio,
after which we will open
up the floor to a Q&A,
and we are really fortunate
to have him here this evening.
Jonathan, welcome back to Yale, back home.
After graduating in 2009,
Jon received Yale's
Parker Huang Fellowship,
which he used to help found Yspaniola,
a nonprofit that began as
a Yale undergraduate group.
Yspaniola is an educational organization
that works with Dominicans
of Haitian descent
who are at risk of statelessness,
and the organization still runs
a university scholarship program,
which Jon started in 2010.
And he spent the early 2010s
between Boston, New York,
and the Dominican Republic
working on film sets,
making his own short films,
and setting up programs
and seeking funding for his nonprofit.
His 2014 short film
"Without the Ancestors"
played at numerous festivals
in the United States and Europe,
including the Pan African Film Festival
and the Zinebi in Bilbao,
and his music videos
with Dominican rappers Chokola Y Gimby
helped launch the duo to
national prominence in DR.
At the beginning of 2014, Jon
travel to the Mojave Desert
to be a field camp manager.
Talk about the versatility
in the talented,
you know, Yale undergraduate.
It's just a range of, I mean,
I've been here for 20 years,
and I'm still completely astounded
at the multifaceted talents
these young people have.
So he became a camp
manager, field camp manager
for a geology class run by
a Yale college classmate.
This trip sparked an
interest in land rights
and geology in the West.
Jon started traveling West
to meet with geologists,
ranchers, Native American
tribes, and archivists.
And after years of research,
writing, and outreach,
his work has led to this remarkable
feature film, "Unconformity."
Along with "Unconformity,"
Jon is currently
in post-production on two short films.
Hopefully, Jonathan, you will tell us
a little bit more about it before the Q&A,
dying to hear more, and
developing many other movies.
And I think, you know, the
testimony to his talent
is that not only was he
just the field camp manager,
but he used that experience
to learn and teach us all
something about the complexities
of what is going on in the West.
So before starting today's event
and we start with the
screening of the film,
I would like to mention a
couple of upcoming events.
So we have an ongoing
Learning by Doing project
for which we are soliciting videos.
These are small science
do-it-at-home experimental videos
that you can send us
that we share with kids
around the world.
And as part of our Understanding
the Nature of Inference
colloquium series, it's
a virtual talk series,
Professor Alexander Paseau,
a distinguished professor
of philosophy at Oxford,
will be giving the talk on
September 28th at 3:00 PM.
And then we have lined up for you
a virtual talk by journalist Esther Honig
on the sad state of
agricultural degradation
in a small Mexican fishing
village in early November.
And later on in November,
we have a very exciting talk
by another of our
illustrious young Yale alums,
the star architect James Ramsey,
who is a former NASA engineer as well,
and he'll be talking
to us on November 10th.
So many treats to come.
And without further ado,
let me just turn over
to Jonathan's film "Unconformity."
And thank you, Jonathan, for being here,
and we're really looking
forward to talking to you
after the screening.
And thanks everyone, once again.
Let's enjoy this film.
(audience applauding)
Very, very moving.
I sort of feel very emotional. (laughs)
There were many aspects about, you know,
academic life, competitiveness,
and our sort of obsession
with the materialistic/consumerist
catalyst culture.
There's just so many things
that we could talk about.
I just want to jumpstart the conversation
and then open it up to everyone else.
So what about your field trip camp,
what really got you
started on sort of looking
at this sort of intersection
of really complex
but really moving, upsetting issues?
- So I was in the desert for a month.
Mostly during the day, I was by myself,
because the geologists
would go out to the field,
and I was actually editing
the film at the time.
So I would edit the film and hang out
with everything else in the desert.
And there were lots of
strange things happening,
'cause we were near Twentynine Palms.
You would run across people, ranchers,
other people out in the desert.
And it was right around
the time that Cliven Bundy
and his family violently
overtook some federal property,
or they weren't paying
their ranching fees.
So I became interested in that and about,
wanted to learn about ranching,
and I went out and met with ranchers
and started hearing their stories.
And the Bundys are obviously extremists,
and the initial drafts of the film
were more about Bundy-style people
with those types of views, but it wasn't,
it ended up where I wanted
to go with the film,
because most ranchers aren't Bundys.
- Right, and I guess somewhere in there,
obviously academic culture fascinates you,
and so I was curious about
that character of Alex.
And so what sort of, was
there a particular person
that inspired you there, or is this,
this is like an archetype that
you kind of pulled out of?
- Yeah, more of an archetype,
more of an archetype,
not one particular person.
And I just, you know, she's very driven,
and she's very focused,
and she's very selfish
in a lot of ways throughout the film,
and it's about her journey
of learning not to be.
But there wasn't a particular
person that inspired it.
But a lot of the academic culture was,
and that sort of competitive nature,
I had a lot of friends
who were in academia
after we all graduated
and hearing their stories
and then honestly my
experiences in the film world
and seeing how people behaved
and trying to get credit.
And so it was a combination
of those things.
- Yeah, well, I thought it
was just beautifully done.
And anyway, I would like
to open up to others
and not hog Jonathan completely.
So if anyone else has questions,
I think there is a roving microphone.
Or did you wanna take this one?
How do we wanna do this?
- [Staff Member] There were
another microphone earlier.
I don't know.
- Can you hear me okay if I speak back?
- Yeah, we can lend our microphones.
I think we're both, thank you.
- [Staff Member] I think just have people-
- Stand up and speak, okay.
- [Staff Member] Because-
- We may not be able
to record this, right?
Or are you recording?
- Oh yeah, no.
Let me just spin this around.
- Oh, okay.
- If you wanna
just have people ask a
question, I'll pick it up.
- Okay.
And we can hear them in the room anyways.
Anyone has a burning question?
(audience member speaks faintly)
(audience chuckles)
- Yes.
- [Audience Member] I'm interested
in the composition of it.
And I guess it would be useful
to hear you say more about the process,
'cause it's a very, very visual film.
You know, like the shots are very-
- [Staff Member] Just talk in there.
(audience laughs)
- Sorry, I'm getting used to this,
and I'm glad it's being recorded.
So I'm thinking about the, I guess the,
your own interest in narrative
and then also image
because it's, you know,
it's very, like I said,
it's a very visual film,
you know, especially the beginning stages
when she's alone and the solitude,
and there's kind of
transcendental insistence,
it's a kind of Edward Hall
and Anna Abbey kind of feel to it.
So I'm interested in hearing you talk
about where in your composing
the images and your
construction of images comes in.
Does that come before
parts of the narrative?
Does it arise out of the narrative.
Do you think, "Okay, I've
worked through the narrative,
and then when we've settled
on a location and all that,
then I'll figure out the images"?
I mean, it doesn't have to be either/or,
but it would be interesting to hear
like the sort of procedural
rhythm, compositional rhythm.
Does that make sense?
- Yeah, so a lot of it
is you find the location
and then you pick the best shot.
A fair amount of it comes from that.
I knew that I wanted a lot
of wides, medium wides,
because I wanted to show
the characters in the space,
and I wanted people to
feel that, so, you know.
When I met with Hana, our
director of photography,
we basically sat down
and planned every single shot in the film.
And what happens often is
you have to cut on the day,
you have to cut a third of them
because you don't have time, but a lot of,
you plan out sort of where you want to,
where the camera goes,
and you develop a style.
You look at reference shots.
I was looking at a lot of photography.
I was looking at a lot of
Robert Adams photography
when we were in pre-production
and showing those images to
her and talking about them.
And then also, you know, some
of the footage that we got
I wasn't even there for,
because we had B-roll.
We had a friend, I had a friend come out,
and we basically talked
about the aesthetic style.
And he came out with his
drone and his camera,
and he went out and spent a couple days
just finding footage.
So it's sort of a
combination of those things.
- Yeah, so actually I did
wanna follow up and ask,
so was there a lot of
drone used for this, or?
- Yeah, and some of
them were pretty obvious
where you see the camera
following or flying
or very high in the sky.
But some of it is, you
know, when you have a camera
on the ground in the
desert, you don't really get
that perspective and that deep view.
And so there are a bunch of still shots
where we just had the camera go up
and look straight out
because it gives you,
it just allows you to see the
contours of the desert better.
And you wouldn't know
that it's a drone shot
because usually you think drone,
you think fancy helicopter-style shots.
And my favorite drone shot is the one
when they're on the ATV,
and the camera just,
it jibs down to the fence,
because in traditional Hollywood,
that shot would've cost by itself
the level of the entire production budget.
But with a drone, you just
have a guy who's talented,
and he does the shot, and it just opens up
what you're able to do, it's really,
and it reads as a jib shot,
which is a technical fun shot.
- I mean, you know, as an astronomer,
I can't resist asking, right?
How come you didn't show the night sky?
- (laughs) 'Cause the camera-
- The stars, they are,
they're so beautiful.
- I know, the camera, so-
- And they're together.
- I'd just read an article
about this new film by
Jordan Peele, "Nope,"
and he used a new photography
method to shoot the sky
that involves infrared
cameras and film cameras
and then superimposing them.
So if we had known about that
four years ago-
- You would've done it.
- We would've done it, but
it wasn't in the cards.
- Well, I mean, I
realize it's about rocks.
I mean, it's not about star space.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- Vic.
- [Vic] By the way, that's
what the Webb telescope
does now, combines infrared
and regular photography.
I just, well, I just wanted
to say, I'm not a film expert.
I've known Jon for a long
time, and in my freshman year
in 1970 at the Law School auditorium,
I went to see "All About Eve,"
and Joseph Mankiewicz himself
was there to answer questions,
and I feel like I'm
continuum for the same thing.
So congratulations.
(audience laughs)
- Thank you.
- Who wants the catch
the box next? (laughs)
- [Audience Member] Jonathan,
it was wonderful to see it
on the big screen after having
seen it on the computer.
and I realized that there
was a lot that I had missed
the first time and a
lot that became clearer.
I was interested in how
you combined the story,
the personality of the young woman,
the main character and the landscape.
What came first to you?
Was it the desolateness of the
desert, or what was it that,
because they all complement
each other obviously,
but what came first when
you were thinking about it?
Or how did you get through
that creative process?
- It's hard to say.
I think part of it was, you know,
I went out to the desert with a friend
who I met the first week at Yale,
and seeing her go out into the desert
and then meeting more geologists,
who they just go out sometimes
for a year by themselves
and live in Death Valley
just doing research.
And of course my experience
out there was formative
to being in that space,
and I became interested
in who does that, who goes out there
and spends time alone like that,
because it's not what most people do.
- So I'm just curious,
from your point of view,
what do you expect the
viewer to take away?
Do you, I mean, do you
have an expectation?
I mean, you must, right?
- I don't know, I try to,
I don't want people to have a
specific reaction to the film.
I want them to enjoy it for
the reasons they enjoy it.
It's a hard question to
ask a filmmaker. (laughs)
- Right.
- Sorry, I don't, yeah.
- (laughs) I know that.
(object clangs)
Oops, but now that you've
seen it all come together,
I mean, was there a portion
of the film, the shooting,
the actual writing, as well as the filming
that was particularly challenging for you?
- I mean, filming in the desert
on a low budget is very hard.
And the biggest logistical
challenge really
was just the distances that, you know,
we were near a small town,
but we were 20 minutes away,
and we were on two different ranches.
You know, we were moving
around the ranches
with a crew and location
and just making sure
everything is in the right
place at the right time is hard
when sometimes you
don't have phone service
or you don't have walkie-talkies.
So that that's a big challenge.
And post-production, you
know, at first I hated it
because it's really painful
to sit with your footage
and try to figure out how
to make a movie out of it.
- Right.
- But then it becomes
this really kind of amazing process
where you just sort of
layer in these elements,
and you get to see the film become
what it is going to become,
and it's really exciting.
So that is challenging
because it takes so much time.
We spent 18 days in principal photography,
a couple days of reshoots,
had to go back to Vegas
to get some B-roll during the pandemic.
But really you're only
filming for 25 days,
and then you spend two
years in an editing room.
- Wow.
- Getting feedback,
doing test screenings, going to festivals,
and doing the music
itself took over a year.
- [Priya] Yeah, it's hauntingly beautiful.
- Yeah, Conor's a-
- It's really, yeah.
- He's an amazing composer.
Yeah, it was a super, that was
an incredible process, too,
because he was, we would
get on a, you know,
we would get on a call and just talk
about what instrumentation
to use, what to do.
And we were on a call together
when the Capitol was stormed.
So every January 6th now,
Conor and I have a reunion
call to commemorate that,
because we just stopped working
and watched the news together, so.
- [Priya] Any other questions?
There's a question in the back.
- [Audience Member] How
did you find the actors?
- We worked at a casting director,
so through one of our producers,
put us in touch with casting
a director who was quite good.
And through sort of a series of events,
we weren't going to work with her,
but then she ended up
being on the project,
and it just opened doors for us
in terms of getting people that were good,
because she was very well respected.
And so, you know, it's
a very low-budget film.
And so agents obviously are
asking for more and more money,
but she was basically able to say,
"Look, this is the project.
This is how much money they have.
Do you wanna be in it?"
And really helped that process.
- I guess next-
- The casting was wonderful.
- Thank you.
- [Audience Member]
Everybody was extremely
believable in their part.
I was very taken by the father.
He could've been a one-dimensional
kind of rancher type,
but you brought out many
different parts of him,
and he had a very expressive face.
- Yes.
- Yeah, he's wonderful.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he was,
Jeremy's a fantastic actor.
He often plays security
guard types on TV shows.
People recognize him, but
he's got an incredible range.
And he is also very fun to have on set.
The first week, we were only
working with Jack and Alex,
the two young actors, and you know,
that were earlier movies for them.
They haven't done very much,
and everyone was kind of nervous.
And Jeremy came the second week
and was just like rolling
around in the dirt
and making dad jokes, and
everyone kind of loosened up.
And so it was really, he was a lot of fun
to have around, and he was great.
- [Audience Member] Jonathan,
it's also my second time watching this,
and I noticed a lot of things this time.
I wanna really congratulate you
on all the breathing
space you gave this movie,
visually and in the
dialogue and in the music.
There's just a lot of, not silence,
but slow down or spaces.
It just, and they spoke a lot to the plot.
And that was my second,
actually more my question
was how you came up
with such a great plot.
Was this something that
kind of came to you at once,
or did it develop after
you started a little bit?
It's a fairly intricate plot,
but it's very, very clear
and very interesting.
And it's like you have a literary flare,
but totally in film. (laughs)
- So there were lots of iterations.
There were lots of drafts,
different storylines
that were completely different than this.
And I even ended up doing
a pretty large rewrite
four months before we filmed.
You just have to sort of test it out,
and a lot of the, you look at, you know,
you study other movies,
you study other scripts.
You see what works in
similar genres or styles.
So a lot of it is sort
of copying the masters
to a certain extent and just
putting it into new places
and testing things out
and having good readers,
people that are
screenwriters and filmmakers.
And honestly, often the
best notes come from actors
because they're so attuned to character.
So you just wanna be open to feedback
and be ready to kill your darlings
because you just have to
to make the script work.
- [Priya] Yep.
- [Audience Member] Just a brief question,
I was very impressed by the accuracy
and the detail of the geology facts.
Any response from the geology community
about these discoveries and things, or?
- The geologists are mostly very,
enjoying it very much, which is exciting.
Recently on Twitter, I saw
someone post a checklist
of all the geology activities
that they got to see in the film.
So they're enjoying it.
- So they approved.
- They approved, they
approved for the most part.
And they're also, they're really,
they're interested in the story
about sort of plagiarism
and bullying in academia.
They're, people are, it's not the,
that's not a reaction I was expecting,
but people are really interested in that
and wanna talk about
that because it's things
that people have experienced.
So there's a lot of interest in that.
- I think we have time
for one more question,
because they expect us to
get out of the room by six.
- [Audience Member] Hi, so
first, thank you for the film.
I have zero academic cinema training,
but I'm a big Western fan.
And I guess the analogy here is not lost.
It's the setting of the saving
the family ranch plot line.
I guess Alex is trying to
save her academic range.
I was wondering how you sort of tie
a film like this together
where usually one expects
some conflict between a, you know,
protagonist and the villain,
and here the conflict,
at least to me and
especially for an academic
trying to do science, the
conflict is not really
against anybody except minor
plagiarism in the beginning.
There isn't really any bad
person to contrast against with.
So I was sort of interested
in how that's sort of used
to generate conflict against,
well, Mother Nature or-
- Yeah, I think that's part of it.
And you know, it's a movie in
part about the climate crisis
and about extinction
events, both big and small,
very old and somewhat new.
So I think that sort of provides
some of the context there
for the conflict and for
Eddie's character, Jason Lowrie,
to also provide that sort
of push to the ranchers,
which was very difficult to
do because a lot, you know,
a lot of the dialogue, I didn't,
you know, you hear, you would talk to BLM,
Bureau of Land Management range cons,
or you'd talk to ranchers,
and they were often
talking past each other
but trying to help each other
in certain ways as well.
And so there was a natural conflict there.
But I really didn't
want to make anyone out,
it's more complex than good and bad,
and I wanted to try to
share that complexity
with some of that conflict.
- Yeah, I mean, and I
think, actually I thought
you succeeded beautifully
because there was this tension
without an illusion to black and white.
And I think I caught the backdrop.
I mean, I like the extinction,
the ancient extinction event
and the contrast with
the current struggle.
And the way that you showed,
you know, the BLM character,
at the end of the day,
we are all in this potential
extinction event together
and a sort of a certain kind of truth.
I actually liked that tension.
I liked the fact that you started off
with that plagiarism thing,
and then that, you were done with it,
you know, that sort of went away.
But that riff was through there
throughout the film, right?
I mean, that sort of carried on.
So I actually liked the fact,
and I sensed sort of tension and conflict,
not so much between good and bad
but between almost like
thriving and survival,
thriving and survival, you know,
academic, thriving, what it takes,
and then it's like down to survival.
And you know, I thought
that those tensions
were really, really well done, so.
- Thank you.
- It was,
I mean, I'm stunned that, you
know, I was going to ask you,
you've not been in a PhD program, right?
- No. (laughs)
- Yeah, so I was pretty stunned
at the sort of the layers
that you managed to get at.
So if there are no further questions,
let's all thank Jonathan
again for a fantastic film.
- Thank you, Priya.
(audience applauding)
- And to many, many more.
- Thank you.
- Yes, yes.
And thank you so much for coming today.
- Of course, of course.